[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
débat consacré aux élections municipales
après Monceau lundi direction Beaune en
Côte-d'Or ce soir avec nous pour ce
débat l'ensemble des têtes de liste
encore présentes au second tour qui aura
donc lieu le 28 juin à l'insulino
bonsoir vous êtes le maire sortant de
Beaune candidats à votre propre
succession membre des républicains
soutenus par les parties de la droite et
du centre
Eric monob bonsoir vous êtes tête de
liste pour la République en marche
arrivé deuxième
tour Carole Bernard bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes tête de liste Europe Écologie Les
Verts soutenu par le Parti socialiste
arrivé troisième au premier tour le 15
mars dernier merci à tous les trois
d'avoir accepté le principe de ce
nouveau débat difficile de le débuter
sans évoquer la crise sanitaire que nous
venons de traverser nous étions vus au
moment du 1er débat et nous n'imaginions
pas qu'il y aurait 15 semaines qui nous
séparerait de ce deuxième débat sur
France 3 le coronavirus qui a tout
chamboulé on imagine à l'insugno que que
ça modifié la vie de la commune vous le
et la vôtre aussi vous le met ressortant
je vais pas dire contraint parce que
l'obligation d'un maire c'est bien sûr
de gérer au mieux les situations
difficiles et ça a été le cas personne
n'avait prévu qu'on aurait trois mois
deux mois un peu plus de confinement des
confinement à gérer et puis surtout des
décisions qui sont venues au
compte-goutte concernant aussi bien
l'ouverture des écoles concernant ce
basket de présence de libération le
périscolaire donc les cantines avec
toutes les difficultés du monde et puis
bien sûr le problème sanitaire j'étais
quasiment à l'hôpital deux fois par
semaine et en Amérique tous les jours
donc on est sur le pont on doit
également créer des solidarités de la
chance de bonnes c'est qu'on a des
associations magnifiques qui auraient
pour dû présente depuis le début de
distribué des masques qu'on a acheté des
masques on les a donné la population on
a fait le travail d'un élu local qui
répondait présent alors qu'on avait
quand même quelques atermoiements au
plus au niveau de l'État est-ce que la
campagne a continué pendant ce temps-là
Éric mono vous qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait pendant 15 semaines
on s'est mis dans un on s'est mis en
retrait dans un premier temps parce que
il y avait un besoin de concorde
national et pendant ce temps là moi je
me suis consacré à mon entreprise que
j'ai dû sécuriser mettre en mettre en
sécurité
on a travaillé avec nos équipes pour
voir comment on allait pouvoir reprendre
avec une petite équipe dans un premier
temps et dans un deuxième temps on a
fait au bout de quelques jours on a pu
faire revenir l'ensemble du personnel et
travailler après un dialogue social
permanent une présence de tout de tous
les jours et puis
je suis comme tous les Benoît
je voudrais avoir une pensée pour
l'aide-soignante décédé
pendant pendant
son service et puis moi j'ai surtout vu
aussi un peu un mélange des gens j'ai vu
un maire qui était plus au manette de sa
campagne que au milieu
a fait son travail monsieur Monot n'est
pas sorti de chez lui attendez
j'aimerais laisser la parole à 40 pour
l'appréciation de de ces 15 semaines de
campagne qu'il n'y a finalement pas
vraiment eu alors moi je voudrais dire
c'est la parole sur sur comment vous
avez géré la crise dans un dire que à
partir du moment où le premier tour n'a
pas été annulé de toute façon il n'y
avait plus de bonnes solutions pour
faire la tenue du second tour déjà il y
a une première erreur au niveau
gouvernemental à ce sujet pour vous il
n'aurait pas fallu organiser le premier
tour si on revoit les choses
rétrospectivement le 12 mars on nous dit
les écoles tous les établissements
scolaires vont fermer le 14 mars on nous
dit tous les commerces non essentiels
bars et restaurants vont fermer mais
malgré tout le vote n'est pas n'est pas
annulé donc je pense qu'il y a quand
même une erreur majeure de ne pas avoir
annulé le vote à ce moment-là ce
résultat il n'en est pas moins légitime
à 57% d'abstention sur notre commune
c'est à dire 12 points de plus que qu'en
2014 on peut quand même se poser la
question de effectivement de la
légitimité
pour autant pendant le confinement nous
la question pour nous la question ne
s'est pas posée il aurait été indécent
de faire campagne il n'était pas
question de faire campagne à ce
moment-là il y a encore un citoyenne
quand même la vie citoyenne est
compliquée par ailleurs je pense que
c'est un moment inédit où chacun s'est
recentré sur à la fois son environnement
personnel et c'est ses obligations
professionnelles moi je suis directrice
d'école et enseignante donc je n'ai pas
assez de travailler et je peux veut dire
que avec
des décisions qui changeaient du jour au
lendemain on a été sur le pont nous
aussi les enseignants tous les week-ends
qui changeaient constamment et encore
jusqu'à il y a peu plus que dimanche
voilà on a encore jeudi prochain lundi
prochain puisque nous a dit que l'école
devenait obligatoire c'est l'instruction
qui est obligatoire mais à la place des
enseignants moi je souhaitais également
les féliciter parce que ils ont été
vraiment souvent pris en porte-à-faux
contre courant les soignants aussi un
moment déterminé je crois que ce qui
s'est passé pendant ces deux mois et
demi a été épique et je dis je reviens
pour les élucos mais je le dis aussi
pour les personnels de santé je le dis
pour les personnels des collectivités
territoriales moi si j'avais pas eu des
personnels qui ont répondu présent aussi
bien les villes avec l'eau je pense
notamment aux heures de ménagers on y
pense pas il a fallu bien les voir
ouvrir les déchetteries ce qui était pas
simple avec des mesures barrières avec
des contingences on me disait un jour
qu'on pouvait le faire le lendemain on
disait bah c'est pas possible donc je
rejoins ce que dit Carole je crois qu'on
est dans une situation où il a fallu
gérer l'urgence vraiment au jour le jour
je vais quand même vous laisser répondre
à Éric mono parce que évidemment on peut
penser que le maire en place quel que
soit la commune d'ailleurs il est aux
manettes et du coup il a un avantage
dans cette situation par rapport à ses
concurrents quel est votre point de vue
la situation est exceptionnelle voudriez
que dans ces glichions le maire de face
rien dans ces conditions il n'est pas sa
population c'est-à-dire qu'il n'aille
pas à l'hôpital à porter son soutien
donner des des masques fvp2 aux
soignants qui n'en n'avaient pas tous à
l'époque donc c'est ce travail de
solidarité c'est le rôle d'un maire
normal tous les maires de France on fait
ça et vous n'y est pas que forcément ça
vous donne un avantage c'est vous qui
allez distribuer les masques quoi
écoutez c'est pas moi qui ai décidé
comme je disais Carole tout à l'heure
que le premier tour de vestenir et on a
personne n'avait envisagé qu'on aurait
cette période-là le maire a dû faire le
travail du maire on lui a reprocher de
la même manière vous faites partie des
rares de votre famille politique qui au
départ ne voulait pas vraiment demande
un premier tour dans ces conditions
parce que dans votre famille politique
on a longtemps poussé la tenue du
premier tour à cette dame j'ai dit qu'à
partir du moment où on commençait à dire
quasiment l'avant veille du scrutin le
Président de la République lui-même que
ça pouvait être dangereux thématiquement
fallait retirer les conséquences et je
dis d'ailleurs pour le 28 juin on pourra
aller voter dans des conditions
sanitaires beaucoup plus sûr et je le
dis on a certainement beaucoup moins de
raison d'avoir peur d'aller voter là
s'il y a une désaffection des urnes
c'est en grande partie parce que les
plus anciens d'entre nous ont eu peur et
on a vu d'ailleurs sur certains
multinules on a trouvé des professions
de foi dans les enveloppes et d'avoir
les bulletins de vote voilà
Eric mon homme sur cette finalement
campagne qui s'est poursuivi côté du
maire vous vous dites
il a fallu improviser qui a fallu
imaginer des solutions
qu'il y avait besoin de présence sur le
terrain
mais moi j'ai plus vu quelqu'un sur
Facebook dans le journal c'est aussi
toute cette campagne qui a été faite
médiatique autour de chacune des actions
je distribue trois masques à trois
personnes
il fallait le faire mais on pouvait
faire moins de
est-ce que vous auriez souhaité par
exemple que dans cette entre deux
citoyens finalement démocratiques le
maire vous associe vous les têtes de
liste encore présentes au second tour à
certaines actions de ce type vous
sollicite je sais pas ça va peut-être on
aurait pu être on aurait pu être associé
ça n'a pas été le cas
c'était plutôt à mon avis Carole Bernard
l'a fait puisqu'on est l'occasion de
discuter ensemble c'était la moindre des
choses en tous les cas de venir je pense
que une tête de liste ou peu importe
n'importe quel citoyen il y a eu 800
Benoît qui sont venus frapper à la porte
pour nous dire comment est-ce qu'on peut
aider nos concitoyens
en revanche on peut dire que Monsieur
sigenot il a quand même pris ses
décisions seule sans les opposants qui
étaient encore membres du conseil
municipal puisque eux par contre n'ont
pas été ni associés aux réunions qui
sont tenues pour la gestion de la crise
ni consulter ni même consulter est-ce
que vous dites vous aussi que à
l'insulino comme Eric mono à l'insulino
à poursuivi sa campagne pendant ce
temps-là pour moi de toute comme je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure la situation à
partir du moment où on avait maintenu le
premier tour est devenu complètement
bâtarde parce qu'on s'est retrouvé sur
la comme d’aglo avec un certain nombre
de maires qui ont été élus au premier
élu ou réélu au premier tour un certain
nombre d'autres maires qui qui ont hâte
qui devaient attendre un second tour et
donc au niveau de la gestion de la
communauté d'agglomération ça a été
quand même enfin assez épique parce que
il a fallu attendre l'installation des
mers élus au premier tour enfin je veux
dire c'est un bazar administratif sans
nom
en visioconférence pour moi assurer le
quotidien vous avez peut-être un peu la
parole
en fait moi ce qui me gêne c'est alors
déjà l'action je trouve qu'elle a pas
été coordonnée
le rôle d'un leader n'achète
d'entreprise c'est c'est aussi
d'anticiper et on voit bien que on n'a
pas beaucoup anticipé anticipé alors
c'est vrai que la situation pouvait être
surprenante il y a eu des ordres et des
contrats mais anticiper ça veut dire
préparer différents scénarios scénarios
incarnia Rio 2 scénario 3 et pour
préparer des scénarios cohérents je
crois qu'il faut travailler en équipe et
c'est pas la force principale d'un
insugnot je vais revenir sur l'image il
y a eu vraiment un mélange des gens
ça c'est pas acceptable un mélange des
gens entre le facebook de la mairie et
le compte Facebook du candidat subnaut
à la minute près à la minute près les
mêmes Facebook du candidat Sud arrêté le
17 mars il y a pas eu aucune
communication depuis cette date-là
effectivement on a indiqué clairement
que on avait dit que clairement de
Monsieur Bono
ou alors le Facebook vous contrôlez pas
les gens le Facebook il existe toujours
vous regardez vous allez regarder oui je
le dis également à nos amis jour de
liste il y a 17h 17 mars au soir on est
dit clairement que par définition
puisqu'on était plus en campagne
électorale il ne s'agissait pas
effectivement dans ces conditions de
continuer à communiquer les seuls
humains qui met en lumière en scène son
maire plusieurs fois par semaine voire
plusieurs fois en période de temps
ou dans le maire il y a eu une
communication il y a eu une
communications
d'avoir géré le quotidien parce que vous
savez d'ailleurs que les ordonnances qui
ont été prises ont demandé au maire bien
évidemment de le faire et dans ces
clichés au maire de te dire informer une
fois par semaine la population de ce qui
allait se passer aussi bien par rapport
aux différentes ouvertures qui allaient
intervenir parce que ça concerne la
population ça s'appelle le devoir
d'information mais vous pourrez regarder
puisque c'est toujours Facebook la
grande chance qu'on a c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ça laisse des traces ça
reste des traces et reprenez les propos
regardez le facebook de Monsieur
crise sanitaire parmi les mesures que
vous avez prises et qui ont été assez
médiatisés il y a le choix de
désinfecter les rues des communes de la
commune des rues de la ville un système
qui a ensuite été décrié en disant que
c'était pas forcément nécessaire et que
c'était pas très écologique je passerai
la parole à Madame Bernard ensuite pour
réagir est-ce que aujourd'hui vous vous
dites j'ai bien fait il fallait le faire
ou est-ce que vous regrettez d'avoir
dépensé de l'argent pour quelque chose
qui ne servait pas forcément j'ai bien
fait d'une part j'ai pas dépensé
d'argent puisque les produits nous ont
été offerts et donc dans ces conditions
et ce sont les mêmes produits qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui pour des affects nos
salles de classe donc c'est des
antiviraux c'est pas de la javel
d'autres communes ont fait ça avec du
chlore nous notre produit par des vision
est inoffensif par rapport à la
végétation et on ne l'a entre guillemets
mis en place que dans les zones où il y
avait des concentrations de population
je pense à l'entrée des supermarchés je
pense à l'entrée des lieux publics qui
fonctionnaient encore bien sûr avec les
mesures barrières et ça a permis en tous
les cas ou surplus de faire prendre
conscience à la population qu'il y avait
un virus et ça permet également par la
suite pédagogiquement de leur apprendre
tout simplement que si on a vu des
masques depuis le début la ville de
Beaune était là-dessus assez pionnière
on pouvait quand même se protéger et
mettre des mesures qui permettent
demain
il me semble que cette crise sanitaire
ce qui est frappant c'est
l'impréparation à laquelle on a dû faire
face par rapport à cette crise et quand
forcément du domaine de la municipalité
mais c'est pas forcément du domaine de
la municipalité en revanche ce qui est
certain c'est que quand on quand on voit
la crise écologique dont cette sanitaire
est une émanation
on peut constater qu'on est encore moins
préparé aux conséquences de la crise
écologique donc nous notre rôle c'est de
c'est de rappeler ça de dire cette crise
sanitaire
qui vient de se passer qui est encore en
cours parce que quand on voit à Pékin
que ça reflement c'est pas une
vaguelette mais bien une deuxième vague
qui risque d'arriver
voilà il est il est grand temps de faire
des plans à partir de maintenant
sanitaire qui tiennent la route vous
auriez désinfecter les rues comme je
pense que je ne serai pas allée sur
cette sur cette pratique
Eric
je pense que quand même
répandre répondre des produits comme ça
sur dans les rues dans toutes les rues
de Beaune c'est quand même une
aberration et des produits bio
c'est quand même une c'est des
antiviraux quand même c'est un antiviral
bio qu'on utilise aujourd'hui sur les
préconisations de la santé en France
dans les écoles
mais pas dans les rues pas parce que
vous savez dans les rues après ils vont
descendre ces produits descendent dans
les nApp on les retrouvera après ils
vont pas ils vont passer dans les
rivières et puis surtout qu'on le fasse
une fois je suis d'accord parce que
parce que c'est vrai que c'était
difficile de prendre des bonnes
décisions et on a le droit de se tromper
mais qu'on insiste malgré les
recommandations des recommandations
sanitaires c'est dommage bon après ça
s'est arrêté et puis
sur l'impact je voulais revenir je
voulais revenir sur non et on sait très
bien que ça servait à rien je veux dire
vous vous passez non pas les masques
[Musique]
on parle pas des masques là parce qu'on
va en parler des masques alors là on
parle on parle du produit qu'on produit
qui a été répandu bon à partir du moment
où on a commencé à avoir des doutes sur
l'efficacité puisque quelqu'un qui
portait le covid pouvait repasser
derrière cinq minutes après et donc le
produit ne faisait plus effet donc on
s'est vite aperçu que c'était et
dangereux et que et que ça ne servait à
pas grand chose donc là il aurait fallu
arrêter plus tôt euh et quand on parle
d'un préparation c'est là c'est là où un
leader c'est quelqu'un qui prévoit et
c'est quelqu'un qui qui prévoit et c'est
quelqu'un quand ici et
là on est on est vraiment dans dans ce
que je constate depuis depuis deux
mandats à l'insulineau on est dans la
grande impréparation je veux dire on se
préoccupe pas du bonheur et l'État
français était très préparé pour les
masques et les tests alors que la ville
de Beaune avait déjà des masques avant
même bien évidemment que on dise que
c'était nécessaire la ville de Beaune
avait entre guillemets je ne sais pas
représentant de l'État français
là où vous voulez revenir mais je je
suis Eric Monod je dirige une entreprise
de 85 personnes à Beaune ou caché
pendant des épidémies et après ça vous
venez faire la morale à ceux qui ont
fait alors je ne me suis pas caché
j'étais présent tous les jours à 6h dans
mon ange
solidairement avec les associations qui
m'ont aidé à distribuer des masques qui
m'ont aidé entre guillemets à mettre en
place une politique de solidarité dans
la ville on peut nous voir je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas été invité et et un certain
nombre de mes colistiers se sont rendus
tous les élus sont rendus les élus qui
sont venus entre guillemets à ma
rencontre ont été bien évidemment
associés et donc la décision n'a pas été
prise unilatéralement elle était prise
avec les gens qui étaient volontaires
c'est la raison pour laquelle on peut
pas faire se reproche des gens qui n'ont
rien fait qui viennent entre guillemets
à la 25e heure vous donner des leçons
voilà alors je vous propose de de parler
de ce qu'il va faire la différence si
vous voulez entre savoir comment comment
numéro de portable
essayez de parler des Gaulois de leur
préoccupations
revenir avec un mot on va vous aurez le
temps vous aurez le temps de vous
exprimer je vous le promets je vous
propose qu'on parle tout ce qui va faire
la différence au-delà de vos rendez-vous
ratés depuis 15 semaines avec les
devants les électeurs le 28 juin les
programmes et les orientations que vous
souhaitez donner à la ville est-ce que
les choses ont changé est-ce que votre
programme a évolué est-ce que vos
priorités ou votre diagnostics ont
évolué durant ces 15 semaines de crise
sanitaire Carole Bernard alors notre
diagnostic
fondamentalement il n'a pas évolué il a
été conforté et validé en fait parce
qu'il s'est passé puisque en tant que
écologiste nous nous avons préparé des
solutions pour adapter la ville au
changement climatique à la chute de la
biodiversité et quelque part à la à une
meilleure solidarité entre les habitants
vous ne pensiez peut-être pas quand même
alors
ce qui est ce qu'on a apporté en plus à
notre programme évidemment c'est des
solutions à la crise économique dans
laquelle nous entrons et qui sera très
profonde puisque le seul épisode qu'on
connaît en référence à cette arrêt
brutal de la production de la
consommation c'est mes 68 et mes 68 ça
n'a duré que quelques jours finalement
et pourtant ça impacté durablement
l'économie française donc là les
projections qui sont à moins 11 points
du pays B jusqu'à -14 points du PIB
c'est ce sont des chiffres qu'on n'a
jamais connu et le pays le enfin pas que
le pays d'ailleurs nous nous allons tous
entrer dans une phase économique qui est
complètement inconnue
Eric mono vous avez changé vos priorités
revu votre programme travailler pendant
ces 15 semaines à changer un peu les
choses oui on a on a beaucoup travaillé
sur notre programme et on l'a repris
repris de A à Z et on n'a pas modifié
normalement de points on a surtout
hiérarchisé les points on s'est aperçu
que notre programme a été enfin on le
savait même notre programme est quand
même assez écologique
et euh de ce côté là donc on a remonté
d'un cran ce plan là et puis surtout on
a imaginé des solutions pour relancer
immédiatement l'économie
des des 29 vous pensez les communes
peuvent jouer un rôle dans la relance
économique c'est pas leur chant d'action
prioritaire mais
elles peuvent pas c'est la région qui
est prioritaire sur le domaine
économique mais effectivement nous nous
avons également prévu un plan de sortie
de crise assorti d'un bilan de ce plan
de sortie de crise et dans l'objectif de
préparer aussi un programme d'action
pour d'autres crises à venir
à partir de notre de notre constat sur
l'état des lieux du patrimoine de la
ville je veux dire on lancera
immédiatement des procédures raccourcis
qui sont pour le moment d'un montant de
40000 euros et qui bientôt passeront
certainement à 80 euros on passera
un programme de rénovation de nos écoles
de de nos chaussées de nos
infrastructures et ça ça va redonner de
l'activité à l'ensemble
mais vous savez on va pas augmenter les
impôts il va falloir faire des emprunts
on est dans une période où il va falloir
diminuer la captation des taxes oui et
il va falloir forcément dépenser comme
le comme le fait l'état on n'a pas
d'autre solution et c'est vrai qu'on
l'hypothèque un peu les générations
derrière mais après une crise comme ça
comment voulez-vous qu'on fasse
autrement à la nouveau si vous avez revu
vos priorités est-ce que vous vous allez
aussi avoir recours à l'emprunt pour
essayer de relancer l'économie
monsieur Monot puisque depuis deux mois
en tant que président d'agglomération on
a réuni en visioconférence l'ensemble
des membres du bureau de l'agglomération
quelque soit leur famille politique pour
convenir de mettre en place un plan de
soutien pour nos petites entreprises en
adéquation avec le plan de la région la
région d'ailleurs a abandonné son projet
et nous a rallié puisque nous mettons en
place dès cet été des Près d'honneur qui
vont être bonifiés y compris par le
système bancaire qui va mettre entre les
entreprises les plus en difficulté une
centaine d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui
sont recensés on les a déjà recensés de
pouvoir sortir de cette période
difficile mais il n'empêche que la crise
économique dont parlait Carole Bernard
est en effet attente je crois que on
aura pour le moment des l'automne des
difficultés et le meilleur moyen de
lutter contre le chômage c'est d'avoir
pris les mesures notre projet initial
sans prévoir le virus notre priorité
c'était l'environnement notre deuxième
priorité c'était la santé et la défense
de notre hôpital et lui donner les
moyens on va y venir on n'est pas stop
pas prévu mais la preuve que notre
programme était collé au d'actualité et
la troisième priorité c'était en effet
les mesures de sécurité vu ce qui se
passait Dijon aujourd'hui très
honnêtement je pense que c'est d'autant
plus d'actualité parce qu'on parle pas
de sécurité
mais c'est vrai que si vous n'y prenez
pas garde on le voit bien d'ailleurs ce
qui aurait pu prévoir ce qui s'est passé
pendant trois jours à Dijon à deux jours
près donc on est dans un contexte où la
sécurité est une priorité c'est le
premier droit des citoyens je pense
qu'une ville comme beau n'a besoin d'une
sécurité la formation parce que si les
jeunes bonnes n'ont pas d'efforts avec
le rendez-vous du chômage du mois de
septembre octobre avec des entreprises
qui ne vont pas reboucher c'est le
meilleur moyen en tous les cas de leur
donner et donner aux entreprises avec un
plan de relance économique en effet les
moyens d'exister tout simplement
d'éviter le choc que l'on va subir
peut-être moins bonne qu'ailleurs mais
qu'on subira comme il y a quelques
semaines lors de notre premier débat les
uns et les autres je vous laisse parler
elle les uns et les autres avaient
beaucoup évoqué l'aspect touristique de
Beaune l'aspect aussi lié au festival à
la culture aujourd'hui tout ça est
quasiment mort
on voit que une bonne sans festival sans
manifestation culturelle c'est une ville
de 22000 habitants et on a aujourd'hui
200 sortes activités qui sont
liotourisme il faut bien sûr les
relancer plus dur qu'ailleurs cette
reprise
donner les mêmes signaux et ceux qui
voulaient enterrer toutes ces
manifestations culturelles aujourd'hui
en ont pris pour leur grade et vous
écoutez la richesse de Beaune elle est
quand même elle s'applique quand même
sur sur une économie et structurellement
fragile de par sa concentration sur sur
certains secteurs d'activité donc là
effectivement ce sont les secteurs qui
ont été
touchés de plein fouet par par le
confinement alors comment on fait et
bien il faut diversifier les activités
et puis là dans un premier temps nous ce
qu'on souhaite mettre en place c'est
aussi une allocation de solidarité
Benoîte pour permettre aux personnes de
comment dire de les soutenir dans ce
dans ce moment difficile cette
diversifier les activités Carole Bernard
mais tous ceux qui aujourd'hui ont du
travail ou du moins avaient avant la
crise du travail à bonne dans le secteur
du tourisme de la culture des festivals
etc ils ont pas forcément envie de
changer d'activité
leur activité oui comment on fait
écoutez moi je pense que le support de
cette allocation de solidarité bonoise
c'est c'est quelque chose qui qui peut
vraiment aider les petites entreprises
je veux dire le restaurant où je suis
allé manger hier soir typiquement il y a
le patron et un salarié ce patron je
sais qu'il ne va pas se verser de
salaire pendant un certain temps donc
cette allocation de solidarité qui est
destinée à ce que chaque personne est au
moins 860 euros c'est à dire la moitié
du revenu médian c'est quelque chose qui
va permettre de de tenir un peu à flot
les les entreprises fragiles
à passer le cap et à ne pas licencier et
vous avez raison je suis d'accord on est
dans votre programme d'action aussi
aider entre guillemets celui comme vous
le dites justement celui qui aujourd'hui
se retrouve en pleine déshérence il a
pas eu de clients pendant des mois ça
commence à redémarrer c'est pour ça que
j'ai souhaité rouvrir très vite
l'Hôtel-Dieu contre la vie souvent des
autorités mais de faire que la
locomotive du tourisme de Baudre
fonctionne parce que la ville de Beaune
sans l'Hôtel-Dieu sans rhume donc il y a
pas que l'Hôtel-Dieu il y a toutes les
projets même de du parc de la cité des
vins demain est un projet
d'investissement lourd qui permet de
donner du travail et des salariés de
créer une le moyen de lutter contre le
chômage et donner surtout la pression
que dans deux ans la ville de Beaune
pourrait sortir par le haut malgré la
crise qu'elle vienne
la relance de la relance de
l'investissement c'est pas encore par
des projets un petit peu bling bling je
veux dire aujourd'hui la vie du tourisme
non je vous ai laissé parler
la relance c'est par des choses
concrètes il faut redonner du travail
aux artisans Benoît donc des projets par
des projets de réhabilitation de nos
bâtiments de réhabilitation de nos
structures parce qu'elles en ont besoin
parce que oui parce que elles en ont
besoin donc ça c'est c'est un premier
acte et puis il y a un deuxième axe il
faut changer de il faut changer de cible
dans le tourisme je veux dire il faut et
on a loupé une occasion on aurait pu
s'associer avec Dijon bon alors c'est
l'ennemi de toujours c'est dommage mais
on aurait pu s'assécher avec Dijon pour
faire une campagne pour faire une
campagne pour faire venir les Français
qui pourront pas partir à l'étranger
dans notre région visiter notre région
venir en Bourgogne venir sur l'acte
Dijon Beaune Mâcon par exemple comment
la route des vins par la route
faire venir
un autre touriste qui peut-être
dépensera pas son argent de la même
manière mais au moins permettra de de
sauver à peu près la la saison et je
vais revenir aussi rapidement a quand
même placé le problème de la sécurité
alors déjà qui prennent position en tant
que mère de Beaune par rapport à ce qui
se fait à Dijon sur son compte facebook
ça ça nous est pas de ça met pas de ça
fait pas de beaucoup de Benoît et puis
en plus je vais jusqu'au réparer juste
vous rappeler quelque chose
on a parlé j'étais à la place là-bas la
dernière fois nous on est prêt à passer
la police municipale a au moins une
quinzaine de personnes avec avec
d'autres fonctions vous avez diminué par
deux
vous avez vous avez divisé par deux la
police municipale c'est une dix
dernières années
de sécurité donc nous on veut pas la
possibilité
d'exister dans les villes et le trafic
de drogue monsieur Bono vous êtes d'une
autre époque vous êtes de l'ancien monde
alors peut-être que cette crise
sanitaire a aussi mis en lumière les
difficultés en matière de santé
vous êtes qui pour me parler comme ça
parce que vous êtes extrêmement
par rapport à une allusion perfide que
vous imaginez bien vous repose de parler
santé si vous le voulez bien parce que
si beau n'est pas un désert médical son
hôpital a été mis en lumière à plusieurs
reprises dans l'actualité triste vous
l'avez rappelé Eric mono il y a quelques
minutes Carole Bernard est-ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'à Beaune on est
suffisamment équipé au niveau sanitaire
ou est-ce que cet hôpital va faire un
objet d'un plan de soutien de votre part
si vous êtes et lumière alors tout
d'abord il me semble que au niveau de la
santé c'est à l'État d'assumer aussi sa
responsabilité comme pour les conseils
mais je veux dire pour l'éducation
nationale comme pour la santé comme pour
la sécurité l'État c'est complètement
désengagé depuis toutes ces dernières
années donc on se retrouve avec une
pénurie de moyens matériel mais surtout
de moyens humains avec des métiers qui
sont essentiels assurées en majorité par
des femmes et qui sont sous-payés donc
là il y a déjà quelque chose à faire à
ce niveau là et je pense que c'est pas
en distribuant des médailles qu'on
arrivera à faire quelque chose mais ça
c'est pour l'État oui mais c'est
important parce que je veux dire chacun
a ses compétences par rapport à ça hier
j'étais devant l'hôpital de Beaune pour
soutenir les
dans un autre cadre parce que je pense
qu'on peut pas tout récupérer
par solidarité voilà est-ce que ça a mis
en lien des choses que vous voudriez
modifier cette crise sanitaire en
matière de santé oui
[Musique]
déjà je pense qu'il faut qu'on recrée du
lien et ça ça peut être un rôle de la
municipalité relié recréer un lien entre
l'hôpital et la médecine de ville je
veux dire ça si ce lien c'est bon avait
été réalisé par des structures je pense
que on aurait plus de facilité à gérer
la crise on n'a pas pu faire un peu plus
de délestage donc ça c'est je dis pas
qu'on a mal fait mais je pense que c'est
un des enseignements qu'il faut qu'il
faut retenir il faudra en tenir compte
il faudra en tirante pour l'avenir et
puis on a vu aussi la nécessité de
s'engager pour soutenir nos capitales
pour faire que cet hôpital ne devienne
pas un hôpital de seconde zone donc il
va falloir enfin accepter de discuter
avec des gens avec salon et de devenir
un un pôle d'excellence dans quelques
spécialités mais on le répète pas
d'excellence dans toutes les spécialités
parce que vous avez déjà de l'avant sur
votre temps de parole à l'insugnaux on a
parlé de bonheur dans l'actualité ces 15
dernières semaines à l'hôpital ailleurs
avec des des voilà des personnes
contaminées parfois oui mais on a parlé
d'un cas et je suis complètement
solidaire bien sûr de Marie Cécile
Poulot qui a été une aide-soignante
remarquable on l'a dit on l'a rendu un
hommage je la connaissais au surplus
parce que elle vivait dans un village
que je connais bien et c'est un réseau
pour lesquelles il faut pas non plus de
voir si le train heureusement qu'on
avait à l'hôpital n'oubliez pas qu'il y
a trois quatre ans si on n'avait pas
créé ce groupement hospital territorial
il y aurait plus depuis à La Baule il y
aurait sûrement des EHPAD de qualité
mais on aurait pu entre guillemets un
hôpital généraliste
si on avait puis on met seulement baissé
les bras on aurait été entre guillemets
les auxiliaires du CHU aujourd'hui bonne
un hôpital il a repris bien évidemment à
travers ses investissements n'oubliez
pas que il y a pas un centime de l'État
dans les investissements de l'hôpital de
Beaune donc c'est donc l'activité de la
vente des vins l'Hôtel Dieu c'est pour
ça qu'il fallait ouvrir très vite qui
participait ça et on a une qualité de
soignants exceptionnel à Beaune et on
peut le dire je crois qu'on a évité le
pire bonne quasiment pas eu de cas de
covid grave c'est notre chance aussi
parce que c'est parce que on a des
affecté les rues on a mis des matchs
j'en sais rien mais c'est aussi parce
que on avait des soignants de très
grande qualité et qu'effectivement on a
eu une ou deux personnes qui étaient en
réanimation pendant le plus longtemps la
structure covid de l'hôpital de Beaune
est fermée depuis trois mois trois
semaines pardon on l'a ouvert il y a 3
mois on le ver la fermer il y a trois
semaines il y a pas eu de cas très grave
tant mieux on a passé à côté de ça mais
je dis que la qualité des soins est
également la pertinence du lien entre la
médecine de ville l'hôpital de Beaune
asserment permis c'est bons résultats
alors je vous propose de parler de ces
électeurs qui ne se sont pas déplacés
57,3% d'abstention au premier tour le 15
mars dernier dans la commune de Beaune
Carole Bernard
c'est eux qui va falloir mobiliser c'est
à eux qu'il va falloir parler pour le 28
juin comment vous comptez dire à ces
électeurs qui vous font défaut de venir
voter
et bien simplement
moi je souhaite leur dire que le projet
écologique que nous portons c'est celui
qui qui a prévu d'améliorer leur vie au
quotidien
en mettant en son cœur trois piliers
l'écologie la démocratie participative
et la solidarité
le projet phare de de notre programme
pour bonne vraiment c'est le projet
alimentaire territorial on veut avec la
communauté d'agglomération un minima
installé ce projet alimentaire
territorial pour permettre à tous nos
concitoyens de d'avoir accès à une
nourriture bio locale de qualité vous
gardez un petit peu de temps vous avez
en une minute de conclusion tout à
l'heure nous dévoilent pas tous que vous
allez dire mais est-ce que
Eric Monod vous avez les moyens de
convaincre les électeurs qui sont pas
déplacés 57,3%
oui
j'ai envie de leur dire que vous les
comprenez
oui parce que c'était un contexte
difficile ils ont été surpris je les
comprends et je les comprends pas parce
que nous étions porteurs d'un projet
d'un projet novateur d'un projet
visionnaire pour beau après à
l'insugnaux a fait du bon travail dans
un premier temps au bout de 25 ans on
est un peu essoufflé et je je comprends
pas pourquoi il est venu se représenter
à cette élection là donc
moi ça m'embête pas de table mais ce que
je pense que on se moque j'ai entendu
j'ai rencontré 3000 Benoît je les ai
entendus ils ne sont pas satisfaits des
services rendus donc nous allons
améliorer le service du quotidien le
quotidien de Benoît nous voulons prendre
soin de du beau noir et ben j'ai envie
de leur dire
levez-vous le 28 déplacez-vous le
changement est possible alors le
changement où le statu quo à l'insugnaux
il y a eu un premier tour il y a une
fête
elle s'envoie pas donc c'est vrai que
c'est quand même un petit peu
après donc c'est vrai que il y a eu
cette désaffection des jeunes pour les
raisons qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
qui n'ont rien à voir avec bien
évidemment le contexte local mais au
niveau national sûrement la peur du
virus mais je crois que par définition
quand on fait près de 3000 voix je sais
pas si c'est les 3000 personnes qui a vu
monsieur monôme il les a pas convaincus
puisqu'ils ont été pour moi donc sa
raison pour laquelle je crois qu'il y a
un rapport de confiance à Beaune et vous
avez 2700 voix de moins il y a 6 ans
Monsieur seguenau c'est sûr qu'avec le
Poitiers avec moitié de 20 ans c'est sûr
que le constat est bien sûr
non c'est pas mathématiques c'est votre
réservoir de voix il est il est chez les
chez les abstentionnistes non le
réservoir il est dans les viennoises et
les boudoirs qui ont marqué déjà au
premier tour un signal très fort en
disant confiance au maire confiance à
l'équipe qui est la sienne par contre on
a eu peur de les voter donc on va se
mobiliser pour le 28 juin tout
simplement parce que les conditions ne
sont plus les mêmes aujourd'hui alors un
vrai projet une vraie équipe voilà
madame messieurs on arrive au terme de
ce débat et on choisi de vous laisser
une minute de conclusion un sablier
virtuel ses graines rares derrière nous
durant 60 secondes votre ordre de
passage a été désigné par tirage au sort
juste avant ce débat et c'est Carole
Bernhard qui débute pour votre minute de
conclusion
et bien cher Benoît charbonnois le 28
juin vous aurez devant vous trois
bulletins le premier le bulletin noir
c'est celui du maire sortant qui a été
élu à la fin du 20e siècle à l'âge que
j'ai aujourd'hui
quand il a été élu pour la première fois
et oui ce bulletin noir c'est celui
d'une politique dépassée gaspilleuse de
ressources et d'argent public il y aura
un bulletin bleu celui du candidat
soutenu par la macronie ce bulletin bleu
c'est changer de tête mais sans changer
de politique et puis il y aura un
bulletin vert le nôtre celui de pourbone
vraiment notre bulletin vert c'est le
seul qui vous permet de voter pour vous
celui qui porte vraiment l'espoir d'une
politique qui qui met au coeur la
solidarité dont nous avons besoin et qui
n'oubliera personne celui qui porte
vraiment l'envie de redonner aux
habitants le pouvoir de participer tout
au long du mandat au choix qu'il est
concerne ce bulletin vert c'est le seul
qui porte vraiment des solutions à la
crise écologique avec notamment un
projet alimentaire pour le territoire
Ambit ce bulletin vert c'est le vôtre
merci Carole Bernard pour 7 minutes de
conclusion c'est à vous à l'insuline
nous puisque vous le tirage au sort vous
a désigné en seconde position mes chers
amis bon est un roman d'amour une
histoire partagée qui nous rassemble qui
me porte également et on l'a vu durant
ces dernières semaines l'expérience est
une valeur sûre à bonne parce que quand
les nuages s'amoncelle et on sait que à
travers la crise sanitaire à travers la
crise économique il s'amoncelle il faut
un capitaine qui sait naviguer il faut
une équipe rassembler qui est à l'écoute
des bonoise et des baudouins il faut
bien sûr un projet qui est un projet de
demain pour bonne nous avons ensemble
grâce au lien de confiance qui nous lie
tous ensemble à Beaune réussi à
construire la bonne d'aujourd'hui j'ai
cru comprendre qu'il y avait d'ailleurs
insatisfait site et par contre nous
sommes là pour construire la bonne de
demain nous servant de l'expérience du
passé mais en nous donnant bien sûr les
moyens d'un projet d'avenir
ce lien nous a permis de voir un projet
qui est un projet de rassemblement
d'équilibre pour la ville qui est
également un projet de respiration
l'environnement est une priorité qui est
un projet de protection notamment pour
les personnes vulnérables pour nous
aider et un projet de protection pour
nos jeunes avec la formation face à la
crise économique merci c'est terminé
Éric mono une minute de conclusion
comme me l'a dit inhabitant de bonnoise
récemment moins de paillettes plus de
concrets plus de concrets dans notre
quotidien pour nous le quotidien le
concret dans le quotidien c'est des
investissements de relance immédiat dans
nos écoles dans notre centre-ville dans
nos quartiers et sur la voirie parce
qu'elles en ont grand besoin c'est une
ville plus verte avec la piétonisation
des pistes cyclables et puis des pistes
des pistes piétonnes une cuisine
centrale pour donner un repas bon par
jour équilibré à chaque petit bout noir
et qui permettra de structurer une
filière qui permettra de structurer une
filière de circuits courts davantage de
services pour les peaux noirs et un
parking de la gare gratuit après 25 ans
de 6 de subnauties élitiste Beaune doit
retrouver son dynamisme le 28 juin
prochain votez pour la seule alternative
crédible choisissez l'avenir choisissez
bonne 2020
osons votons changée merci merci à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à ce débat
dans un instant votre journal régional
une belle soirée à tous sur France 3